according to OECD international testing
Australian students were lagging
seriously behind their peers in other
developed countries when it comes to
mathematics you your math genius do you
like it and we're about to be joined by
someone who appear on Australian story
tonight but also arguably the most
famous maths teacher in Australia it's a
very good morning to mr. Eddie whoo
Heidi come on yeah it's great to be here
with you um your math journey you didn't
really like it as a kid did you to start
with no it certainly wasn't a natural
thing for me I loved English and history
I loved writing things and stories that
was sort of my natural language but
mathematics we kind of always there and
I didn't mind it but certainly it wasn't
my favorite subject to begin with so
then how did you go from there to where
you are now people from all over the
country and all over the world coming to
you for math lessons look it was a very
sliding doors moment to be honest I was
standing in line at the Faculty of
Education at Sydney University on
enrollment day and I had there in my
hands my enrollment form to become a
student in The Bachelor of Education
Bachelor of Science combined
sorry Bachelor of Arts combined degree
and I had on the form you know English
and history as my teaching areas and I'm
standing there sort of just looking up
and down my paperwork when the Associate
Dean of the universe a collation walked
by and he just plucked my academic
transcript out of my hand looked at my
form looked at me and without any more
of a word he said you should be a math
teacher and he spent the next 20 minutes
explaining to me how we have this acute
shortage of trained passionate
mathematics teachers which still hasn't
changed
today we still have that shortage and
for me I always wanted to go into
teaching because I want to make a
difference to children's lives I mean I
enjoy my subject but for me it's about
it's our students and it's about people
and you know what it give me any subject
and I'll teach that so I want it to be
where I could be most useful and that
happens to be mathematics right now we
say right now does that mean that you
will eventually like to return to maybe
that first basic love of the humanities
well I think I've found myself rather
entrenched in this world to be fair but
I guess I would say that I actually
bring a lot of
my love story and narrative and
theatricality to the way that I teach
mathematics and I think that resonates
with the students - okay so tell me
about Wu tube which I love by the way it
was actually a joke told by one of my I
was because students always come up with
the best ones I was literally this was
years and years ago before I started
doing this and someone said to me in my
roll call class you ten boy he said he
sure wouldn't be really funny if you
started a YouTube channel and you called
it would you and you know of course
being a doesn't lessen boy said exactly
like that yeah and you know we all had a
good laugh and then when I started doing
this I couldn't think of a better name
and no it's stuck so where it started
was that I had a student who was very
very ill he was diagnosed with cancer in
fact and you know cancer is a life
changing reality for anyone let alone a
16 year old boy and all of a sudden his
life was just turned upside down it
couldn't be at school for weeks and
weeks at a time often within a term we'd
see him for two or three weeks and then
he'd be just gone and it's difficult to
go through life under circumstances like
that but I remember when my mother was
diagnosed with cancer when I was in high
school one of the things that you most
want as a person who's sick or affected
by sickness you just want to feel normal
you just you don't want to be singled
out and pointed out in law there's that
is the kid who's sick or there's the kid
who has all these family issues and this
boy he just wanted to keep on learning
with us and have that part of his life
still be normal and something where he
could excel because he was really good
at the subject and so because he
couldn't be in class I took my phone
I propped it up on the table and I just
hit record and it wasn't heard very good
because it was pretty shoddy quality
back then but you could see the
whiteboard you could hear my voice and
that's where it began I put him online
because that was just the easiest way to
get them to him and it didn't take long
for other people to take notice well you
say that I mean when did you realize
that a lot of people and I mean a lot of
people were tuning in for your math
lessons I it was look when one of my
students came to me one after
noon it was in that same year and they
said ah sir I met my friend from his
other school and she said hey Gino this
mr. Wu guy and it slowly dawned on me
and her that there were other teachers
around to discover the videos and they
were showing it to their students and
it's just kind of spreading from there
that was a weird moment I think probably
the the first moment when I was I think
honestly I was like buying I was at the
butcher buying some chicken wings and
the person handing me the meat sort of
gave it to me put it in my hand and it
sort of gave me this sideways looked and
said do you teach maths by any chance
and that was when I thought okay this is
this is sort of become something else
but every time it's still weird because
I'm just an ordinary teacher doing my
ordinary thing in class every day and
the videos are just a window to that
that's all
well inquiring minds want to know you
know you're a man of figures being you
know a mathematics teacher are you
making any money out of it at all
look I'm not I mean one of the things
for me is that I have I've received an
education for free I mean I went to
public schools my entire life and
honestly if a student at home is going
to spend the time and take the
initiative to go and look up videos on
math to learn and study in their own
time the last thing I want to do is put
a pre-roll ad in front of them and put
an obstacle to their learning so for me
this is not about you know getting an
income it's about spreading learning and
I've I've just been so privileged to
receive a great education myself I
really want to pay it forward to the
next generation it's 18 minutes to 10
and Eddie woo who's head of mathematics
at cherrybrook Technology High School in
Sydney is actually going to be the
subject of Australian stories now but
we're speaking to him now this is after
he set up his freely accessible website
woo tube to help the student who had
cancer and has become an internet
sensation as teaching people all around
this country and also the world I mean
is it a great example Eddie that the
nature of great teaching doesn't mean
the proximity has to be someone right in
front of you giving that lecture style
in an explanation
look it's been amazing for technology to
open so many doors I've been really
privileged to get in touch with
people from around the state some of the
people who you'll hear in the episode
tonight are people I've never met but
they're in rural and remote areas and
because technology opens all these doors
it's just brilliant that they have
access to something which otherwise
would be almost impossible for them to
get and for that to even go you know
around the world and to people not just
in schools I've gotten comments and
emails from people who have long left
high school or any kind of formal
education and are realising actually you
know I never really got this back in the
day but it's great to be able to have
someone explain to me in a way that I
understand I got a Christmas card last
year by from a 50 year old dentist and
he wrote this email his this card to me
to say you know this concept I've never
heard it explained it before in such a
clear way and I really enjoyed it so
thank you to someone who you obviously
went to school 3035 years ago but it's
still willing to learn and I love that
now when you do all your filming for
YouTube for example me is asking do you
actually film in the classroom because
here in South Australia teachers aren't
allowed any recording devices in the
classroom or do you do this separately I
do this in the classroom I mean it's
it's worth pointing out that what I do
is I position I just use an iPad in on
top of a tripod in the middle of my
classroom and I do angle it so that all
you can see is the whiteboard and me you
can hear my students voices which is
important because most of my lessons are
me talking back and forth with them
wouldn't make much sense and if you
could only hear me but you never see
them on camera unless it's something
special that they've signed permission
for and you know for me it's it's all
about just providing access to that
explanation and making sure it's done in
a way that's sensitive to their needs
so it's done live I have three young
children and all these other kinds of
responsibilities as a head of department
so I don't have the time to pre-record a
project or die so it's it's the live
experience so what do you students think
well I mean you talk about setting that
iPad up etc I mean what do they think
that mr. woo is doing that and not only
that is going to be on something like
Australian story and they're making a
fuss of their teacher look I think it's
pretty funny for them a lot of them the
first time that they see me set it up
maybe the first couple times not
this is a bit weird think I'm going to
relocate to another part of the
classroom it's a little further away
from all of this gear but very quickly
then normalized to it I mean I wish
unfulfilled is you know not that we'd
for them but I do think you know it's
quite it's quite charming for some of
them that they recognize you know what
teaching is important work teachers
don't get heaps of status or pay in this
country and so for them to recognize oh
yeah you know what educators are worth
putting on a show like that I think it's
been a pleasant surprise for all of you
sound so positive Eddie where you sound
like you're just continually moving
forward and kicking these great goals
and doing these great initiatives do you
ever have rough days or rough students
our teachers have rough days all the
time I mean I have a.m. at our school we
have six periods in the day that we can
teach and sometimes I'll teach a class
before school and if I've got seven
periods in a row I can guarantee you
some of those will be great and some
will be ordinary and you know one of the
great things about being in public
school in a comprehensive school is that
we get the whole range of students we
get students who are academic stars who
are just sort of they're the kinds of
kids you hope they're not going to ask
you a question because it's so bright
you probably can't answer their question
and at the same time you've got kids who
come from a background of disadvantage
or maybe they don't have heaps of
support at home or they have gaps in
their learning and it's a privilege to
take those kids and be able to say look
I'm going to take you to the next spot
where you need to be learning wherever
you are coming from whatever gaps you
might have my role is to bring you
forward to be able to increase your
confidence in being able to do things
and be able to go out into the world
solve problems and that's you know it's
exciting yet hard teaching is hard there
are long hours I know people say 9:00 to
3:00 but I don't know any good teacher
who works from 9:00 to 3:00 we do lots
of preparation beforehand and lots of
marking and report afterwards but it's
worth it because you can see the
difference that
makes in children's lives every day and
you even if you're lucky get to have
students come back to you years later
and they say officer
I don't always what I always gave you a
hard time but now I'm doing this you
know I'm in the finance world I'm a
successful plumber I'm a whatever it
might happen to be and that's just
that's just endlessly exciting to me I
mean I have every reason to be positive
about the work that I do it's a great
privilege
so then Eddie whoo where are we going
wrong why do you think we are lagging so
far behind low in all of this
international testing other developed
countries when it comes to mathematics
yeah look the first thing I'd probably
say is that it's difficult to make broad
and sweeping statements on things like
the Tim's or peas our reports firstly
because I'm not a trained statistician
statistician so I'm speaking from my
experience in the classroom but also I
know from having looked at these
documents myself there's a huge amount
of complexity in these documents and you
know things that it's difficult to take
into account diversity and what have you
I'll give you an example
lots of comparisons have been made with
countries like say Finland and their
amazing education systems and there's
certainly things that we have to learn
from there but the Finnish education
system versus our education system I
mean our societies are completely
different in terms of the diversity of
the students that we have in our
classrooms and so it's very difficult to
make comparisons but I'd probably say
maybe two things that I can think of
areas that we need to work on and the
first thing is that it's become sort of
popular and almost something that you
can have with pride to say yeah yeah I
never I never understood math when I was
at school and you know I I was kind of
fine and the thing is when we say that
when I whenever I hear that said I I can
hear the pin drop in a student's mind
when they realize oh you know what that
means I can just sort of leave this
behind and not you know put myself
through the rigors of trying to
understand this because it's too hard
yeah I'll be doing any lemon out yeah
yeah that's right and so there's a
there's a real cultural shift that I
think that needs to happen because the
truth is and mathematics is for everyone
I'm
you know not everyone's going to climb
Mount Everest not everyone is a
superstar mathematician but we can all
enjoy the climb I mentioned before maths
was not my strong suit at school but I
spent lots of time trying to wrap my
head around it I haven't given up and
for me one of the major things that I
want to teach my students that I want to
convey to them and to my own children is
that if something is it easy will you
persevere and you don't give up like
that's a life lesson that's not a maths
lesson so I think that you know that
cultural angle and also the the
willingness of students to be able to
say you know what just like JFK said
when he was trying to inspire relation
to come together in the middle of the
Cold War he said we would choose to go
to the moon not because it's easy but
because it's hard and for students to
want to do something challenging I mean
children of all ages throughout you know
for centuries have always wanted to take
the easy path but we want to encourage
them to actually set your eyes on
something higher and mathematics
numeracy patterns shapes they're an
important thing in our society today
that everyone needs to wrap their head
around so I think if we can help kids
understand that they'll really give
Massacre Eddie whoo it's been delightful
listening to you Jenny from Port Lincoln
for example says congratulations mr. woo
you're inspiring as a retired teacher
I'm delighted the profession is in such
good hands so thank you all the very
best and look forward to seeing you
tonight on Australian storing and
channeling mr. woo which will be on air
from 8 o'clock on ABC and ABC iView
thanks so much Eddie there's a pleasure
Ali thank you